ihre freude und wir sind wieder berg mit
einem neuen video heute machen wir ewig
gehen und zwar habt ihr euch das wieder
gewünscht die kitchen eine gebühr auf
die schüler kommen beim neuen video und
jetzt fragt ihr euch am ball ist im out
steht auch schon wieder werbevideo weil
dieses mal edeka mich gefragt hat ob ich
nicht wieder teilen die kitchen machen
kann und zwar haben sie auch die
schwierigkeitsstufe erhöht und wollen
dass ich alles grille und dafür hab ich
sogar ein teil gefunden der im internet
aussah wie ein igel und dann habe ich
ihn bekommen und da stand aschenbecher
haben dass sie was können wir zum
servieren benutzen ein aschenbecher in
welchem supermarkt fahren wir denn da
gibt es doch so ein sohn gelb-blauen
haben so ein cate blanchet fällt mir
nicht ein lasst uns einfach zu edeka
gehen okay vielleicht sollte ich noch
erwähnen dass es wieder ein drei gänge
menü wird also vorspeise hauptspeise und
es her ich habe ja schon ein paar
gedanken gemacht was ich meinen gästen
servieren möchte und zwar wird es dieses
mal gemüsespieße zur vorspeise ein
burger ein baby burger mit pommes zum
hauptgang und zum nachtisch der ferrari
noch nicht abblocken geheimnis was gilt
sie denn zum nachtisch und jetzt dass es
wirklich zu edeka weil unsere gäste
die imaginären kommt mit
[Musik]
hierauf vorbereitet und habe schon eine
einkaufsliste gemacht sie ist ziemlich
lang
also lasst uns lustig ich glaube ich
habe noch nie zu den schönen erstmal das
gemüse wenn wir hier sind viele menschen
merken sie sind perfekt wir haben uns
für den allgemeinen eisbergsalat
entschieden umgehend jeder
[Musik]
er schafft es nach hause eine grillparty
start
mein name ist vanessa heute ihr chef
lassen sie sich auf eine raumfahrt der
extraklasse machen sich bereit als
küchenchef muss man schlau vorgehen und
deshalb kümmern wir uns als erstes um
die brötchen von unserem welchen burger
achtung rezepte rezept habe ich mir
natürlich aus gedacht war und bei den
brötchen wollte ich nicht diese normalen
bürger brötchen machen sondern diese
amerikanischen etwas süßer in bürger
brötchen habe ich einmal gegessen und
fand ich super
dafür bitten schuss milch wir brauchen
unsere frische hefe hier für alle die
letzte mal gesagt haben
wo ihr das ich bin wieder im feeling wie
komisch aussah so damit wir das so
besser verarbeiten können
das müssen wir als verrühren heute muss
ich auch gesehen ein halber table soccer
das kam mir immer nicht merken ob
[Musik]
1400 gramm typ 550
und 10 reilly
stellen buckle einholen soll ist da muss
nämlich noch eigene bude ein
wir brauchen jetzt ein viertel davon wo
es gibt gar nicht mal so schlecht und
butter die ganze vorwürfe der frau als
schwierige wird ja eigentlich ist die
challenge dass man ja alles grillen sei
man könnte ja versuchen das burger
brötchen auch zu grillen ich mein wenn
man den kredit zu macht dann ist das ja
bin so rufen was eine küchenmaschine ich
muss gucken ob ich so eine ganz kleine
kirche
[Musik]
wir brauchen jetzt eine prise salz und
ich habe einen ganzen wald streuer
gefunden so auf jeden fall haben wir
diesen bald da muss noch nicht perfekt
sein
wir haben den anfang gemacht weil eine
hilfe zeigen natürlich erstmal auf denen
muss und in der zeit können wir dann
ganz in ruhe die kästen gang vorbereiten
kommen wir jetzt zu unserem ersten gang
gemüsespieße und dafür brauchen wir
gewaschenes gemüse und hat noch
grillkäse gekauft weil ich natürlich
kein fleisch wein machen wollte und
grillkäse publikum statt große
schaftlich spieße benutzen wir ein
zahnstocher ja erfahre dem ich die
abdeckung verloren habe und jetzt liegt
immer hier so ein kleines messer und die
leute denken ich bin eine session keine
kitchen assassin
[Musik]
ich habe sogar gelbe zucchini gefunden
was ich absolut klasse fand karin i kick
gewinner zucchini
die brauche ich kleine stücke unserem
kleinen jetzt haben wir riesige
champions league eine kleinere gefunden
champignons nicht waschen sondern nur
den schmutz ab machen das habe ich bei
jan tamtam gelernt was ihr am tamtam ist
ein youtube channel von edeka was für
ein zufall und passierte - so grillkäse
dieses jahr eigentlich schon gegrillt
ich habe mir anfang des jahres nur ein
grill geholt und seitdem bei mir jeden
tag wenn sie grill party angesagt kein
gemüse spieß oder zwiebeln naja ist ja
auch mal eure tipps ab ich bin ich zu
faul auf der bibel noch was drauf jetzt
machen oder später an abgenommen und
nochmal ein grill geben
wunderschön aber zu wenig käse ich mache
jetzt noch ein paar und dann sehen wir
uns gleich wieder kommen wieder zugang
nummer 2 zum zweiten gang machen wir
burger und pommes
wir ersparen uns arbeit und machen so
geile pommes matches sieht aus wie ein
account rekord hält keiner so schlecht
auszusehen so oder so und das machen wir
jetzt so lange bis wir eine schale voll
com ist haben
ich hab sogar kleine ponys gemacht sie
sehen es so süß aus
also ich hab noch nie in meinem leben so
tolle promise gewinn stellt sich
natürlich die frage kommt auf dem pass
noch was drauf kommen auf den kommissar
auf ja klar
kurkuma und paprika würzen und braten
damit sie schön knusprig werden die
mitunter kleinlaut afrika pulver und
salze hoch erhitzt das brauchen wir
und jetzt alles verrühren also wo sie
sind kleinen löwen diese bands zu
früheren so das kann jetzt schon ein
ziehen
die marinade und jetzt machen wir weiter
mit unseren körpern und david grohl mein
gott ja mit zu kleinen bands formen wie
das hier ausgesetzt
luftig daher gebildet hat herr die von
euch wissen wer mein kameramann ist
heute ist es benjamin brötchen macht so
gut so diesen wunderschönen tag müssen
wir jetzt in kleine bällchen dafür
lieben wir uns besser und schneiden
für mich wie ein pizzabäcker und so
ungefähr sollten die dann aussehen
global unsere bürger brötchen müssen
sich jetzt noch ein letztes mal ausruhen
und in der zeit kümmern wir uns um
networker wälder
das wichtigste bei so einem burger ist
natürlich dass patti und hier habe ich
zwei variationen gekauft und zwar ist
das einmal aus so weizen und soja
gemisch und eins mit linsen und gemüse
ich darf das benutzen jetzt mal das
schon bessere geprägt ist die dicke die
wir brauchen und hier auch einmal das
ist aber natürlich noch zu groß und wir
müssen das ausstanzen und kleine machen
nicht ein burger paddy so okay wir
brauchen einen käse stift was den großen
wie seht ihr die waffe stunde und der
bürger kommen wir natürlich nicht nur
käse sondern auch köpfchen und wörtchen
sind ein bisschen zu groß und deshalb
habe ich keine chance geholt ich weiß
nicht ob man die college jungs aus
strich keine chance monitor ist mein
bester freund immer kontakt zu sagen ihr
könnt jetzt mir gerne in die kommentare
schreiben wie man es besser aussprechen
kann man sowas von nam le coq dass wir
so eine säge
das reicht natürlich nicht nur komisch
aus sondern auch frische tomaten große
schau dir das doch mal an
es sieht so niedlich aus und dann noch
das hier dazu spieße mit unsere bürger
bringt sie noch so richtig schön
goldbraun werden
der nun etwas aussehen machen jetzt noch
eine eier milch mischung mit dem wir sie
dann bestreichen so und wenn jetzt alles
gestrichen hat dann kommen unsere saison
könne
[Musik]
die burger king hält es für ein
wundervoller tag zum grillen
ja ich stelle das jetzt einfach mal so
direkter reihen
wir hoffen einfach das beste zehn
minuten lang und in der zeit in der
jetzt unsere bürger brötchen grill sind
schreiben wir jetzt anders und andere
das ist schon geschnitten wie wir
gemerkt haben aber brauchen auch für
sich was für ein zufall
ich wollte gerade nach dem brötchen
schauen was erinnert mich das ich weiß
es nicht
nun es ist an der zeit sich um das tier
zu kümmern und zwar machen wir karamell
ich hoffe das klappt ich glaube nicht
dass dieser topf dafür geeignet ist weil
er jetzt schon vom letzten mal
angebrannt und ich sag mal so wir müssen
uns extrem aufpassen bei zucker mit sehr
heiß und es kann sehr doll weh tue wenn
es auf der haut ich versuche es einfach
nur zwei fahren die bessere gewinnt
möge der bessere gewinnen hatte ich
glaube da unten passiert schon was eine
ewigkeit später hier machen
das kann man jetzt salz rhein mit dass
jetzt schon diesen seiten schmöker
kleine planänderung ich glaube nämlich
wenn man die früchte zu klein
geschnitten jetzt in das flüssige
karamell gibt dass sie halt so und
realisiert werden das kann fell sein
aber was uns das mal versuchen
ich meine karamellisierte früchte so wie
ich versuche dann gut
ich mache auch schon was in der formel 1
waren wir fertig haben können wir
endlich anfangen zu grillen und als
erstes möchte ich so eine kleine schale
bauen für die com ist weil die müssen ja
irgendwie nichts gehört werden dann ab
zum grill und jetzt heißt es warten
37 sekunden später
wir servieren den ersten gang momentane
teelicht als vorspann hätte ich gerne
die gemüsespieße zum hauptgang den
bürgern schritte und als nachtisch das
karamell alja das nehme ich danke auch
an bier bitte auch bei coop da ist kein
schaum drauf danke brust ne tolle tolle
sanierung super es ist das mini grad
herrschen löcher ein bisschen vornehmer
hier hier müssen wir mit messer und
gabel essen
das ist ein bisschen krieg gibt es
durchwegs mit paprika messestadt zu
kenia bezug
mein gott das vergesse und jetzt stellen
uns natürlich wieder der allerwichtigste
frage wie schmeckt einen super teil drei
gänge menü vom grill mit illegal
ich hätte gerne den nächsten song der so
nie fertig den muss ich selbst mache ich
mir jetzt hattenberger das sind übrigens
unsere bürger brötchen aus dem grill das
hat richtig gut funktioniert ich habe
sie noch nicht abgeschnitten vor dass
sie mir jetzt einfach mal perfekt
geworden so berger brötchen kommt jetzt
ketchup senf und mario und nun folgt
auch schon das perfekt gebratene darauf
natürlich eine scheibe von der gis
körbchen tomaten kommt noch ein bisschen
burger soße gut gemeint weil der mich
komplett verarschen schau dir an wie zb
aussieht das sieht auch durch spiel
essen
hey wenn man das politisch decke
geklauten folgen ja ok da kann man
nichts machen dann kommt in mein
hauptgang und dank m
der sieht ja fantastisch aus und so eine
große portion er ich hab noch kommissar
zugestellt dankeschön ja super 8 mensch
im mittelpunkt wir uns einmal darüber
unterhalten wie fantastisch das aussieht
es ist einfach ein burger sieht man
sieht sogar die minigurken und dem mini
tomaten und käse und dass sie ein
bisschen aus wie krabben bürger was
probleme zuerst die pommes lecker mega
gut gewürzte die blätter auf jeden fall
etwas kürzer drin sein können dass
bürger brötchen ist der hammer aber zu
klein
bekomme ich mein appell für den
nachtisch brauchen wir tahiti vanille
eis von edeka was ich schon kennen und
super lecker das stört mich jetzt hier
und auch das eis kommen jetzt
karamellisierte früchte corny wie viel
so hätten wir ein problem und zwar
unsere karamell stücke hier sind jetzt
alle zerbrochen in der tiefe nicht
geschlossen wenn ihr sowas machen wollt
bitte auf dem backblech so wie man es
über liest und nicht im keller weil ihr
denkt ihr ist es besser man eigentlich
wollte ich so stäbchen haaren in die
luft gehen deshalb auch so gut punkt
sind ja wenn ich nicht so blöd gewesen
wären dass auf dem teller gepackt
danke das ist vanilleeis mit früchte
karamell und karamell sortie karamell
crunch wow erstmal das vanilleeis von
elika seiner empfehlung ich kaufe mir
das immer früchte karamell und dieses
crash hätte ich das besser hinkriegt wer
das richtig gut geworden aber so es ist
schon kann ich habe noch nie so was
gegessen absolute meisterin geworden
danke ihr dk für diese challenge aber
natürlich habe ich sie wieder mit da
wohl gemeistert ihr könnt das nicht
entscheiden oder beurteilen ich sage
euch das vertraut mir ich hab es super
gemacht hat aber mal wieder viel zu
lange gedauert wir waren jetzt seit
memphis schon sieben stunden wieder
andrehen
ich meine wenn karamell auch eine stunde
auf der pfanne liegt ist es überhaupt
nicht flüssig wird
da kann man sich das mal vorstellen und
damit ist das video auch schon zu ende
ich bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei edeka
dass sie mir ihr vertrauen geschenkt
haben und
gesagt haben wir deshalb grill mal drei
gänge den teil
ich muss auch wenn keine gerichte zu
machen danke an euch fürs zuschauen ich
hoffe natürlich hat es wieder gefallen
wenn ja zeigt es mir auf jeden fall mit
einem daumen nach oben
aktiviert die glocke wenn ihr keine
neuen videos verpassen wollt abonniert
diesen kanal wenn ihr ein teil dieses
teams sein wollt team und wir sehen uns
beim nächsten video wieder war es
hoffentlich nicht keine kitchen sein
strengt du dich gebe ich jetzt ins bett
legen
ich bin noch mehr von diesem ist also
[Musik]